um
after covering little ground on the
first few days of my journey i spend the
next four days hurtling through the
state of schleswig-holstein
it's not always easy on the first day i
managed just 21 kilometers due to
serious headwinds
then after a gut busting 57 clicks on
day two i only clock up 41 on the next
day
my bicycle sat nav leads me onto a muddy
byway and i have to carry my scooter for
five kilometers
at the end of day four though i'm proud
to have put another 52 kilometers behind
me
crossing the federal state of whitby
holstein by scooter makes my pulse go up
to more than 100 after several hours
i'm quite done despite my advanced
training
how am i supposed to complete the entire
trip through germany
on this contract
my odyssey which began on the island of
zilt exactly one week ago has now
brought me across schliswick holstein to
the baltic coast
by the time i pull into a place with the
exotic name brazil
i've covered 214 kilometers
wait a minute brazil
i'm standing here at the beach at brazil
and i thought the copacabana
would look quite different i don't feel
like
dancing the summer
i asked passersby about the origins of
the name and don't hear the same theory
twice
one thinks it's called that to keep the
residents from moving abroad
another says confidently that it's
because wreckage from a ship named
brasilia
washed ashore here yet another says he's
read that it's because the fishermen who
used to live here in the 18th century
began to emigrate in remembrance of
those who'd left the people who remained
named the spot after the most exotic
place they knew brazil
there's no way to track down how the
quarter came to be called this but it's
not all that uncommon for german
villages and even towns to have unusual
names there's a rome in germany as well
as a philadelphia a california a
bethlehem a russia
and even a canada but let's get back to
brazil
looks nice though perhaps not quite as
tropical as you might wish
and it has a major drawback no scooters
allowed
so i stripped down to my swimming trunks
and just acts like the cool day is
hot hot hot and that i'm on the beach in
sunny south america
it's all about willpower
okay enough of that so does the name
actually affect the way people approach
life here
what do you say does the fact that this
district is called brazil change your
approach to life
well often when it's cloudy and hidden
off it's sunny here
the weather today bears that out
the name apparently has left its mark on
the local culture
we provide an exclusive view of the
schleswig-holstein version
of the brazilian zumba
ah that's what i love most about that
south american feeling
swing your hips move your feet it's time
to
dance some of the people who live here
at least have caught brazil fever
just like a native fantastic
now ronald joins in on the dance floor
not quite as traditional as you might
expect but
certainly enthusiastic
i'm speechless the samba's top notch and
some of these poses could have been
struck by pele himself
here on the baltic coast the people
really do have a touch of tropical
passion
the town quarters named brazilian means
brazil
it has a vivid cultural life and the
climate doesn't look
as bad as at first glance january may
have 13 rainy days
but june on average has only 10 it is
way better
than in the rainforest with a slight
sunburn and my head full of sambar
rhythms i withdraw with a smile from
this exotic enclave in the high north
it isn't quite the copacabana but it
comes close okay
not really but even so i say obrigado
brazil
i hop back on my wheels take the next
turn and head
south another 72 days in front of me
crossing germany by scooter